und zu unserem nächsten Thema der
umstrittene Sänger Xavier Naidoo sorgt
mal wieder für Schlagzeilen in den
letzten Jahren fiel der Musiker weniger
durch seine Musik auf sondern durch das
was er verbreitete nämlich
verschwörungserzählungen hören wir mal
zu Erinnerung in einige seiner Aussagen
rein wir sind nicht frei wir sind immer
noch ein besetztes Land Deutschland hat
kein Friedensvertrag und ich komme immer
mit Details raus adrenochrom
diese Dinger hier
die sind für den Arsch wir können das
nicht mitmachen nicht nur dass Sie
unsere Wirtschaft an die Wand fahren sie
bringen unsere alten um
Nähe zu reichsbürgern Antisemitismus und
Leugner der corona-pandemie das ist ganz
schön verschwurbelt und er hatte in
Kreisen von verschwörungsideologen viele
Unterstützer jetzt dabei zeigt sich
Naidoo geläutet distanziert sich
plötzlich von seinen
verschwörungserzählungen der Krieg in
der Ukraine habe ihm die Augen geöffnet
ich habe mich Theorien Sichtweisen und
teilweise auch Gruppierungen geöffnet
und den ich mich ohne Wenn und Aber
distanziere und los sage
ich war von verschwörungserzählungen
geblendet und habe sie nicht genug
hinterfragt habe mich zum Teil
instrumentalisieren lassen
gut drei Minuten lang ist das Video von
Xavier Naidoo konkret also wovon und wem
er sich genau distanziert das sagt er
nicht
ja über das Video von Xavier Naidoo und
Verschwörungsideologien möchte ich jetzt
mit Katharina nokun sprechen sie ist
netzaktivistin Politikwissenschaftlerin
und Expertin auf dem Gebiet der
verschwörungserzählung guten Morgen Frau
Neukunden guten Morgen Frau Kunden wir
bewerten sie denn dieses Video von
Xavier Naidoo vollzieht er da wirklich
eine 180 Grad Wende oder ist das eine
PR-Nummer
naja genau das wissen wir eben alles
noch nicht die Erfahrung mit der Szene
macht sehr vorsichtig es gab in den
letzten Jahren immer wieder Fälle bei
denen Prominente Akteure aus der Szene
gesagt haben nein ich verbreite keine
Verschwörungstheorien im Anschluss haben
sie aber weitergemacht wie bisher es gab
auch immer wieder Distanzierungen aus
dem Milieu wo es hieß wir haben nichts
mit Rechtsextremisten und Antisemiten zu
tun gleichzeitig hat man sich aber nicht
an reichsbürgern in den eigenen Reihen
gestört und man muss ja sagen das Xavier
Naidoo da in den letzten zehn Jahren
muss man ja sagen eine sehr große Nähe
auch zum Reichsbürger Milieu gehabt hat
das sind sehr radikale Gruppierungen und
von daher würde ich sagen warten wir
erstmal ab was da folgt
es ist denn überhaupt möglich wenn man
so tief in einer verschwörungsblase drin
steckt wie sie das gerade bei Xavier
Naidoo auch beschrieben haben dass man
auf einmal durch einen Schlüsselerlebnis
in seinem Fall sagt er ja es sei der
Krieg in der Ukraine gewesen von heute
auf morgen dann seine Meinung ändert
ja die Wege zum Ausstieg raus aus der
Szene sind ganz unterschiedlich was wir
tatsächlich immer wieder hören auch von
Aussteigern ist dass es bei ihnen
irgendwann klick gemacht hat was das
ausgelöst hat ist aber total
unterschiedlich manchmal war es einfach
das beharrliche Gespräch immer wieder
mit Freunden und Verwandten die gesagt
haben schau doch mal und hier ist ein
Faktencheck und hast du das schon mal
bedacht und sie haben Fragen gestellt
das kann irgendwann wirken oder aber das
ist wirklich so eine Ereignis was einen
aufrüttelt also das beispielsweise
jahrelang eine bestimmte Prophezeiung
gemacht wurde über eine Ereignis und die
Realität sieht dann sehr offensichtlich
ganz anders aus und zwar so dass man
sich das auch nicht mehr durch
irgendwelche Rationalisierungen
zurechtlegen kann wo man einfach klar
einsehen muss ich bin dann den falschen
gefolgt und die Wege raus sind ganz
unterschiedlich muss man sagen was genau
hinter diesem Statement steckt werden
wir wahrscheinlich erst in den nächsten
Wochen erfahren
täuscht denn der Eindruck dass Anhänger
von verschwörungserzählungen häufig
Überschneidungen bei Themen finden wir
haben das jetzt in diesem Fall auch
gesehen also sind corona-leugner auch
häufiger putinversteher oder
flüchtlingsgegner
es gibt sehr große Überschneidungen in
diesem Milieu man muss dazu sagen dass
russische Staatsmedien seit vielen
Jahren eine große Rolle in der Szene
spielen und zwar auch schon 2014 als der
Krieg in der Ukraine begann damals der
Einmarsch auch die Krim der Krieg im
sonnenbass schon damals hat Warschau
today von den sogenannten
montagsmahnwachen für den Frieden
berichtet wo eben auch über die Wochen
hinweg sich immer stärker gezeigt hat
dass dort verschwörungsideologen den Ton
angeben und auch bei pegida gab es eine
sehr große Nähe man hat
Rechtsextremisten auch Anhänger von sehr
radikalen rechtsextremen
verschwörungserzählungen eine Bühne
gegeben und von daher wundert das nicht
dass wir auch in den letzten Wochen
immer wieder auf
verschwörungsideologischen Demos
Russland fahren und ja putinenversteher
reden gesehen haben ja sie haben die
Propaganda gerade angesprochen welche
Rolle spielen denn die sozialen Medien
insbesondere auch der messenger-dienst
Telegramm
eine sehr große vor allem auch in der
Pandemie und man muss sagen dass gerade
auf der lokalen Ebene telegram natürlich
auch eine sehr große Rolle spielt um
Events zu organisieren und Proteste zu
organisieren teilweise wird über
elektronische Medien über Gruppen über
Foren auch ja sage ich mal der soziale
Kontakt kompensiert der an anderer
Stelle wegbricht weil vielleicht die
Familie der Freundeskreis sich abwendet
weil sie sagen das was du verbreites ist
mir zu krass und ich möchte auch nicht
die ganze Zeit von dir bekehrt werden
außerdem ist es natürlich so dass
Nachrichten über telegram häufig in der
verschwörungsideologischen Szene
verbreitet werden und in den letzten
Wochen sind ja auch einige Fälle bekannt
geworden wo sogar ja Anschläge in
Führung mordkomplotte über den Messenger
geplant wurden Katharina nocun Expertin
für verschwörungserzählungen ich bedanke
mich herzlich für das Gespräch heute
morgen gerne